[Applause]
[Music]
my top three girls congratulations
one of you will be inducted into the
drag race hall of fame
well hello to the top three how does it
feel to have that secret out in the
world after months and months and months
a year
[Laughter]
a year okay 365 days
[Music]
do you each feel like you were do you
each feel like you were able to
accomplish what you wanted to accomplish
by going back to drag race
you know for for me my goal was to
uh a make it to the end so check you
know and b
show people this version of me i call
her good juju and i think that
i think that she's here and i think i
think y'all see that
yeah and we got to meet amber
amber with the urr amber
do you feel like you accomplished what
you wanted to accomplish
yeah when i left filming i just felt
really
at peace with everything because i knew
that i just went in there
and gave it my 100 percent
best and most authentic self and that's
what i wanted to do and uh it real i'm
really glad to look back and watch the
show
and see the person that i have grown
into from my time
on season nine and cracker
i'm jewish i'm always anxious about what
i've accomplished
i am a jew so i get to say it that way
you do not all right you guys teased to
me when we first
talked to the beginning of season that
there was going to be some unresolved
drama that you hoped would
unfold on the show there may or may not
have been a little drama that we
experienced
and i think that maybe watching the
season we might get to find out the
truth
because we know it was never really
resolved i don't know
i don't know what you're talking about
either i don't know what you're talking
about and you don't know either derek
which we now know is the alexis
india was there or was there not a
campaign going on to get shay out of
this competition
when i was in the bottom you and mayhem
came up to her telling her that she
should choose my lipstick
i did that to you india when do we know
the truth today do we feel like we have
an answer today
i i you know you know what you know what
i can say
my campaign slogan is jujube for msg
2020.
and vice versa yeah
i'm confused i don't know we all
are and i think that that's the point we
don't know because it really happened
just between
alexis and india i feel like i've just
like created my
own resolution for myself just from what
i've like seen
on the show and perhaps what was
presented to me was just like a very
tiny portion of the truth that was
delivered in a way from my anxiety and
the competition
to like take it and run wild with it and
i think that's kind of how
it all spiraled out of control because
like
i heard something really sinister from
india and
um i don't know if that was her chance
for me to
hear it as sinister i just know how
people make me feel and i just love
alexis mateo so much another moment that
was
almost sinister was cracker you almost
you played with us you toyed with our
emotions you gave us the naomi manila
moment for a second
my gut has already told me what to do
but i'm like is there any
other choice
[Music]
can you imagine
shay i gotta know what you thought when
you saw that play out on tv
i was cracking up like i was just cuz
like
you know we have all the these moments
you know where we
are filming by ourselves making these
decisions doing these things so like
you know we don't i've never even
considered it
so when i saw it on tv i just started
dying because i was just all like it was
it was it was
really hilarious
it was like it was theater it was a
moment of comply you brought us crap and
i'm a
theater kid so you know i love a good
old
exactly what cracker was doing was
turning the mirror around to the
fandom and letting them take a good look
at themselves
that's what i was doing i'll be your
mirror
yeah let's do some rapid fire about the
season
on that note what was the hardest vote
for you guys to cast
mine was mariah
mine was blair what was your favorite
look of the season
mine would have to be jujube's finale
runway
holy [ __ ] when you guys see it
you're gonna die you're gonna die
oh i died she didn't understand what the
word finale was pronounced like she
thought it was
finally as in i'm just finally do
something
like finally
my favorite look had to be actually
uh i loved the shades
i love the skinner and look i the fully
rhinestone with i
that is that is like probably one of the
best looks that has been on that runway
and i love your hair cracker i love your
hair
just generally i love blair's um prom
look
i thought it was just immaculate just
really important
all right what was the quote of the
season for you the thing that you know
the drag race fandom will be calling
back to you for years oh
i don't know oh they'll be quoting back
to you
hmm well i'll turn it up to a sensible
74
and turn up the thermostat to a sensible
74.
[Music]
i feel like that and then what i think
cracker was starting to do here which
was the sh
moment are going to live on it from this
she walked to the end of the runway and
she went
chew
[Music]
everybody one two three
what was your favorite lip sync of the
season oh my gosh
i got to see monet for uh
one of the lip syncs and i got to see
juju in
leopard print which is her favorite so
that was
i'd say that was mine that was a joyful
one
wow yeah that was my favorite lip sync
too
for myself i would have to say even
though it's not like technically
a lipstick i think our final top three
production
is real chess kiss oh okay
shay is putting in the work here to get
people to tune in for the finale she
said there is a look that you won't
believe in a performance you won't
believe
vh1 needs to send an extra check in the
mail to you today
yes juju you mentioned to me when we
first talked to the top of the season
that you were a little nervous about how
this
evolved audience was going to interact
with you
and i feel like it was good how did you
feel
uh i'm honestly i'm very grateful to
still be able to
to do drag the way the way that i'm
doing it now and we
definitely there's a completely
different audience now than what i had
before
it's insane i mean the love is there but
i also
i i hope that the fandom
could choose to just love right and and
um because i see a lot of negative
things out there too and i think that
that makes us all uncomfortable and it's
unnecessary
so i i just hope that the fans could
could
watch this and see that we love each
other and we support each other and just
spread love
there's actually yeah there's there's
actually a video going around this week
that i think cracker you're a part of of
some of the drag race family saying like
enough is enough with
racism in the uh the fandom i have never
had a fan or someone pose as a fan
write me and just call me flat out
never until i got on drag race what are
some actionable items you would like to
see the fans do to
keep this community positive i think
juju said it best in an earlier
interview don't be racist
don't be racist no don't just stop it
yeah wash your hands don't be racist
watch drag race
wear a mask wear a mask yeah
um bringing it back to fan response
shae and cracker how would you say the
all-stars experience was different
from your initial season experience
i would have to say my all-stars
experience was different from season
nine
and the way that um
i've actually had a lot of fun
interacting
um with the fans um
there's so many really sweet ones out
there
and it's been
great getting a chance to talk to them
and engage and develop like these little
funnel
online relationships it's cute i mean
every season we see more and more people
um engaging with drag through social
media and i think
it's a beautiful thing because it means
the art that means the most to me means
a lot to other people too
i feel like we did get to know you all
on a little bit deeper level this time
around than the first time around
i mean shay we got to experience the
story of your family
juju you opened up about your sobriety
and cracker we got to know more about
your childhood
what did it mean to each of you to share
those pieces of yourself
on national television well
it was important to tell people that art
has been a part of my dna
since i was born i wanted people to know
that that this is not a hobby for me
um i think that having the
opportunity to be um more
vulnerable and show the human side
of drag that i feel like sometimes
people forget about
was important it's nice to be able to
kind of
pull back the facade of what people get
to see just on social media and show a
little bit more truth in humanity
it's it's the ability to separate our
art
with our heart if that if that resonates
with us right and being available for
rupaul
uh i needed that so badly i i wouldn't
be here today
without those friends i wouldn't be here
i don't know what that did for rue but
for for rue to be able to open up like
that i think was really beautiful
and oftentimes we don't get to see that
vulnerable side of rupaul because this
is rupaul this is supermodel in the
world
you know so um i'm i'm glad that i
brought my tears
and then and then made her laugh and cry
and i
we felt every emotion in 30 seconds yes
and
all of america watching felt every
emotion in 30 seconds
all right each of you friday night the
crown's on your head i want to go
one by one what does that crown mean to
you the crown for me
means that i have made it into
this world of being one of the one of
the great drag queens
being at the top of her game um and i
think all of us could agree with that
like we're
we want this crown and the title i mean
keep the money
just give me the title and the crown
that's what i that's what i want and um
you know i hope third time's a charm
because there's not going to be a fourth
time [ __ ]
[Laughter]
shay what about you what would that
crown mean
um that crown would mean
that i would be able to keep the promise
that i made long ago to
baby kool-aid that if i won i would use
my 100 000
to get her a set of dog stairs up to the
bed
and she has been such a good girl and i
feel like she deserves it and i really
want to bring home those stairs for me
that's an expensive flight of stairs
she deserves it
and cracker a chance to prove that
comedy can make a difference
i love that all right we got that lip
sync assassin twist it was really fun to
watch
i think fans were so eager each week
who's gonna be there
is there anybody that you were
disappointed didn't come out
to give you a run for literally your
money i
for for a split second i actually
thought raven was going to come out to
lip-sync against me
during that thing and i was like oh god
here i go dancing on my own again
like is this gonna happen and then i saw
monet and i was like oh my god can y'all
bring raven back
i can because i can't do this against
monet
well you know there's a lot of fan
speculation that one week you were going
to show up behind that curtain like all
of a sudden you would disappear from
where the girls were sitting
be the lip-sync of sex yeah and still
not in other words right imagine
sharecracker anybody else you would have
liked to seen come and
put on a show i would love to see
cameron come back and do a
lip sync with her uh a rematch but also
just because
she's been so supportive and amazing um
in the years since
season 10 and it would be a great way to
sort of
like redo that ending well i would say
i would love to see uh
trinity k bonet i think she's a really
terrific
lip sync assassin or my chicago sister
dieter ritz
um i would love to have seen her
um and it's been a minute since we've
had some cheesecake
we did have what did you call it
crackers
cream cheese pie
i love it you come back and do a
lipstick assassin
y'all um yeah why not
because you know we were saying this
earlier and then interview i didn't win
um rupaul calls what was it i said
rupaul
rupaul is like your bladder in your 30s
when she calls you go
there it is there it is
we will leave it on that note because i
can't think of anything better
thank you guys congratulations